welcome to this video about the final
round of the Chess Olympiad 2012 in
Istanbul and here we hit very very
interesting final round today and yeah
congratulations to the new Olympic
champions I'm coming from amenia um yeah
I simply can't resist you to mention
that this was my pic before the
tournament but ok it's a matter of luck
those kind of guessing games ok I'm it's
been um very am very close in the final
standings with a minium sharing first
place with Russia they both um scored 19
points out of 11 rounds so 22 points
would have been the maximum so both
teams conceded just done one loss and
one draw Russia lost against the United
States i covered the Nakamura game just
two days ago and amenia lost one match
against China and they both them get
through their match 22 so on both teams
really am with a great performance enter
certainly a two gold medals well they
don't want them but this kind of score
usually is enough to win the tournament
let's let's put it this way and this
time two teams managed to do it third
place goes to Ukraine with 18 points
they lost just two matches but 19
matches also um yeah still a good
performance but they lost key matches
against them yeah against both amenia
and Russia and yeah fourth place goes to
China and yeah this is the story of the
wrong China was leading before the final
round but they needed to beat Ukraine
but lost 3-1 so China had yeah the gold
yeah in the hands already but spoiled it
with the loss
again the middle d very strong team from
Ukraine I'll cover the game even shotgun
against one how simply because it really
yeah set the tone for this match and it
was obvious early on that Yvonne Shull
had some pressure and that would be very
difficult for China to win this matches
a loss is hard to compensate mean they
would have needed to win to 22 games out
of four then and it simply didn't look
like it even um at the end they lost
bought four also yeah and also let me
quickly check the funnel standing in the
women competition yeah here russia won
the title a bit surprising liam as china
was leading the event throughout but shy
not simply m yes bought the tournament
for them with a very unexpected 2-2 tie
against Gaveston in the penultimate
round they were leading by one point and
simply had other the bigger teams
already beaten or played and they simply
simply needed to yeah beat the somewhat
weaker teams but what failed with a
mention to 2-2 tie against avastin in
fact russia played Gaveston the last
round in 140 so it was possible to beat
them so Russia first place China second
place both with 19 points also and
unbeaten so three draws conceded three
ties and third place yeah just like in
the men's competition or the open
section ukraine ukraine with 18 points
they also didn't lose a match just four
drawers um okay let's um go to the
featured game I don't want to bring up
any more statistics they're interesting
ones like the individual bought medals
and so on but then if you enjoy i'm
looking at the detailed results I'll put
them linked to the results page
just very am yeah very informative it's
got lots of data to consume I'll put
this in so that you can read it and
click on it in the description all right
let's go to advantage of one how you
want your plate one deform and okay you
never know what is going to play you can
play any opening and we actually get an
image of Indian with e3 the Rubenstein
yeah event took really plays all opening
so it doesn't make any sense to say okay
he's an expert there has experience in
this kind of opening is simply plays
everything ok one hull with castles no
Bishop d3 d4 Knight f3 so one of the
absolute main position some of this
opening here the overwhelming main line
is C 5 which usually usually is answered
by castles and then like has a choice
you can play can play em can play this
cap off variation and this was covered
in earlier game I'm of the Olympian
between Arkady knowledge and Peter lake
or where knowledge what a nice game here
with the isolated pawn but there are
multitude of variations really possible
in the game um one now played b6 which
is some somewhat rare a move but um one
that still enjoys pretty solid
reputation but it seems that if one
should played an interesting line they
played the immediate a three I'm the
main move here by farm is castles and
Bishop d7 and this is somewhat different
the differences if white now plays a
three to ask the bishop what it is doing
and then then black likes idea is to
retreat to the 60 wants to keep the
bishop and put up some sort of set up
with nine be 37 queen e seven
maybe oops maybe 86 to prevent this this
kind of move so black really wants to
keep the bishop he doesn't want to
retreat it he wants to treat it he
doesn't want to capture on c3 and the
difference in the the main game here way
bunch of play day three if black now
intends to keep the bishop and retreats
it then white has some the interesting
movie form at his disposal of course in
the other line where blacks bishop is
already on b7 this move would simply
lose the PCM but here white has enough
control on only form and black gum
doesn't have much else to to take him
and this looks some slightly more
comfortable for white with the nice
Center and like has lost some time with
this bishop moves the bishop even isn't
particularly well placed on d6 it would
rather be only seven in this structure
so this is why black also took him and
yeah now white gained the bishop pair
but ok in the names oh this is kind of
normal and in fact I think um you could
easily a.m. if you look at them the
finish of the game you could easily
think that it was a smooth sailing all
around and white was yeah what was much
better and so on but i think it's not so
clear really likes position was very
solid all around yeah he played an
interesting concept he played c6 on the
basic alternative would have been to yet
to capture here and play this kind of
firm this kind of setup also very
standard nims o pneuma play and maybe
here while preparing a form and this
kind of position should be M yeah very
slightly better for white just because
he is probably able to play your form in
in the future but them it's um so fairly
normal structure like an
I can certainly play this he went with
c6 however which is interesting the
ideas that black wants to fight for the
c-4 square and instead intends to
recapture with C porn um we see this in
the game where one shook 2pm and now
black can recapture with the C porn um
we very much prefers this to to caption
with the e porn as look at the e pawn
capture gives while an extra porn in the
center and this really intends to
quickly exchanged this Bishop if
possible or set up some blockade on the
Seaforths clam so it's an interesting
way to play as blankets not yeah not in
wanted show black or anything but it's a
certainly am a viable strategical idea
um tweeny tubers played just to prevent
Bishop a six and now Knight to c6 which
um intends to support this kind of
blockade on the c4 square cancels and 95
according to plan the drawback however
of this move from yeah is that it
neglects the five square and we see this
soon the same point a form to allow the
bishop activation here ruki aided sort
of anticipates Bishop a three and now 95
now White has a very strong knight on d5
and this was possible because black put
this night on the edge of the board um
from a yeah personal taste kind of
perspective I would really like I really
like YTM but maybe it's um it's not so
problematic yet like 94 which is
probably okay the idea is to go to d6
I'm one notable motif iya that I'd like
to show us if black wants to play 97 to
quickly get rid of the night only five
then white already has the decisive move
takes them oh sorry I confused it sorry
I looked at my notes yeah but no it's
actually this one Bishop age seven is
not not bad also but Nadia seven is even
stronger just taking here the idea being
check that um yeah where should black
skin go let's say goes here then she has
this move and we see the benefit of a
form Bishop on a three and up like as in
a deadly crossfire this is check um
getting getting checkmated I guess check
check this was i I could I could I could
have could have taken here this is just
click on check and now it's it's made on
age seven yeah man i def seven is some
as deadly this kind of combination with
f7 and h7 being the critical points
crops off pretty often of a bishop is on
d3 and not only five black needs to be
really cautious with moving and away
defenders okay study plate m94 jars of
course blocks this diagonal yeah now I
played f3 kicking the night away of
course it cannot take simply because
after this the night has no squares it
simply get lost gets lost after let's
say this move and now next move our
capture the night so he goes to the six
which was the idea anyway strengthening
the blade on on see form covering f7 so
um like a decent um defensive maneuver
push of a three others not much not much
not what else what this Bishop could do
and here's an interesting position he
played Bishop d7 now which still might
be okay here I had a look at the move f6
which was my first idea simply to try to
get rid of the night and he certainly
thought about this if I'm sure because
you have a look at this if white would
really move the night now to reform it
yeah it doesn't have a really good good
place on g4 where should it go it
doesn't have any direct detecting ideas
in fact the problem with their goodness
f6 movies i think is to reply f form
simply am sacrificing a PCM and this
leads to an exceptionally strong a tech
forum for white I think it's very hard
to defend this I can give you an example
some sample variations of black takes
the night instantly then why'd would
first capture here and like now
recaptures in fact you could analyze a
form right thing why does some simply
better in this position computer still
things that's equal but I don't I don't
get it really white has all the ideas on
the Kings Island black has no play it's
still fairly solid but why should be
better okay what I want to show really
the attacking ideas if black gum simply
retakes and takes here then here we see
a very very nice attacking position
black not only has one move he needs to
play this year instead cover the rook
because of Queen age five and yeah of
course this is hanging h6 just simply
loses instantly to checkmate on h7 so
black needs to play g6 and now of course
what sacrifice
and here black guy only has got one
movie plates needs to play rupee seven
if he takes the bishop check yeah simply
devastating this is also why Queen d7
was the only move because black needs
this rookie 7 move to to get things
covered and here I think I'm yeah why
does probably just winning the only
thing you need to do is yeah keep cool
about how this just retreat and now wide
pants up like this rook f6 rook f1 Queen
h6 this is not defensible it's just too
much another cooler taking ideas rook a
2 2 f2 and at first I think the computer
gives us as I don't know equal slightly
better for white or something but i
think what is just women I didn't bother
to let it run for a couple of minutes or
so I think white white will win this um
with not not much problems the computer
will also show this i'm pretty sure you
only need to let it let it run for a
couple of minutes maybe okay this is
just a very strong attacking position if
we return to this idea f6f oh i just
want to show one more line if black now
doesn't take which is yeah simply simply
too risky you could play here and use
this be four square then white has the
very strong move Queen aged 5 and this
is some a bit similar to the to the the
other line but i think he is even more
amazing okay this simply has the idea of
giving a check made or check first then
96 rook f3 this kind of check made this
way but okay what happens if black takes
it we simply recapture just taking only
five and now the problem is that the f
squares firmly controlled and white them
now can with ya all the time in the
world pile up let's say like would play
this move what would somebody take and
play rook f7 and there's absolutely
nothing but black can do against rook f1
and rook takes g7 it's just it just
deadly let's say King here rupiah and
I'm threatening group takes 3-7 and
there's nothing black can do to prevent
this you can try okay you can try it
something like this then I go here look
age four and it's over it's simply too
much firepower on the king and note that
these pieces yeah really don't help and
it's very nice very nice attacking lines
so here rock edge forces simply simply
deadly let's say something like this
check check me and it's made on some
other weights it's just it's just over
so f6 I could have led to some pretty
interesting attacking lines you played
we should be seven though and now even
shook oops I hit the wrong button here
oops now even shook just took on d6
recaptures an F for the idea was he
wanted to play a form but didn't want it
to allow 94 so it took the night first
and then play there for ya and here we
have from the same kind of threat again
that are they showed before this kind of
problem if black would play something
like this check this is just check check
this just enter the game and meet next
move so black must be cautious again
about these two points so played g6
covering the center yeah planting the
diagonal yeah white improved his Queen
now going to deform for will be
intending also
flac f5 and black now with 924 attacking
oops not this one attacking III oops I
didn't intend to do this but oh it's fun
alright then in it takes III and white
cover this yeah change my keyboard yeah
because my usual one has some technical
problems and this keyboard i dented the
right right key CM okay why done simply
cavity 3 of course if you look at this
white could could also think about
taking here but you need to be careful
this kind of stuff really gets like huge
counterplay you don't want to exchange
your night really this is such a strong
piece only five so green g3 looks just
about right maybe rook 81 was also okay
but this is certainly a good move yeah
and this is some the critical position
really I mean white certainly has them
more comfortable position he's got a
good night only five queen is
aggressively plays he got the F porn and
so on white is certainly better this is
not not the huge um yeah discussion i
guess but still I think I'm like had
chances to put a tougher resistance him
um maybe young one idea could have been
to play something like whoopsie aid and
the the point is that the move had one
how played allowed and yeah some
attacking scheme which this move on some
others even would prevent I'll show the
game first and then you see the problem
with his move he played Quincy seven and
now White has a very strong continuation
which even shocked of course spotted it
took the lives and now played f5
and this is very strong now the problem
is that um like um yeah would like to
recapture do it to capture on f5 then
rupee at five and in the other position
where black had the Queen still on d6
like would be able to play f6 which now
of course simply taken so to compare if
black doesn't make this unlucky move
here like and place this then the same
kind of line like SF 6 and you cannot
check on g6 because yeah like exchanges
Queens and wins apiece so f6 is now
possible the Queen kavitha spawn so it's
just a very small detail but it changes
the position considerably so this is
actually the losing move after after
this because black simply doesn't have
yeah nem any play will move as mentioned
this is a very very problematic here f7
is just under such heavy fire let's
continue this a bit rookie 7r okay to f1
and maybe he'll commit like this then
you get this kind of position well why
didn't completely dominates on the dark
squares and he will simply push the H
porn and at some point sacrifice on g6
while black has absolutely no play at
all of course there are other ideas what
can also try something like this I mean
this it's terrible like Becca's just
yeah waiting to get to get beat down him
so taking wasn't really a wasn't really
great and what should like do if he
plays let's say this one to cover f7
then what simply pushes him and he's got
all this kind of ideas with an
with this night only five it says it's
simply a one and like a not in any way
get rid of this and the dark squares
it's terrible so black played f6 which
yeah also loses but it was it was lost
anyway and now white them yakin can
really finish this install he took on g6
simply ignoring that the noid is hanging
okay black took it not much choice this
kind of move was simply answered with
him I mean this certainly would win also
what this is even more devastating or
white can simply pile up more it's
terrible okay it took only five and now
the force will move rook at seven taking
the Queen and the h7 pawn and yeah
there's nothing really that black it do
we played this let's look briefly at
briefly at alternatives rookie seven for
example then why'd simply plays this
move and threatened this was check made
and yeah black has no moves it's simply
m and simply over if you would may move
the age phone then why tell ya multiple
wins one possible witness this all can
also go here it's simply it's simply too
much this kind of stuff okay in the game
he played Queen to c6 and now white to
break through it with this capture
sacrificing the rube check and he had
only needs one more precise movement
this is the Queen the new queen on h8
okay like needs to take it and now Queen
g7 the point was to get the rook 2 h8 so
then if black now goes to the background
he'll get
you get checkmated in this fashion or in
this case loses a queen so in the game
you actually went to went to g6 now
after she takes d5 while the the
official site gives the move Kingda five
it's being played and yeah I'm not sure
resign so i overstepped the time but
this position White has a fast made with
the route 31 check King here and yeah
the most human way to check made now as
clergy for check this even one this is
one move with wicker shown by the
computer and yeah to me it's made on d 2
yeah very nice King hunt at the end
touch wasn't completely played out so
after King King to d5 quite sure why the
buttons are not working I'm not sure I
simply cannot move back here okay so
after King d5 or while playing king d 51
how I'm resigned so very nice game at
the end for you one show cassette who
had them yeah sort of up and down
tournament some some good games and some
yeah somewhat weird games yeah I hope
you enjoyed this noise attacking game by
by Yvonne shook and yeah I've made 11
videos on this Olympiad them some or
most of them while I was on vacation and
during the time I didn't do any other
content so um yeah in this upcoming week
out certainly do some more uploads which
is some yes somewhat which will be
somewhat different like couple of rapid
or blitz games or maybe some online
tournaments so a little bit of more
yeah lighter more entertaining stuff
then those some yeah longer time control
games playbook run masters yeah hope you
enjoyed it and yes check the channel for
new videos